e credo
che bisogna spesso oggi proveremo altre
modo per pochi
la
donna segreto anche se forse magari lo
vedrete tantissimo
ma come vi piace molto perché 100
milioni di sistemi non mi piace
proveremo altri bond o sisley time to
die miconi brady bond carne è sicura e
un nuovo partito via allora mettiamo
subito la cassetta così di canto abbiamo
già fatto qualcosa non devo dire che mi
sono affezionata a questa fabbrica di
giocattoli ormai mi piace stare qua
l'inquietante
bello sarebbe esplorarla nella vita
reale
e di abusi ricordiamo bene
troppo brava voi possa ricordare
grappa che vediamo se questa volta le
mani avranno qualcosa di diverso se
avete visto l'episodio proviamo la mode
di ben di capirete che cosa tendiamo
un'altra cosa che mi piace un sacco di
questo gioco
[Musica]
sembra dico una cosa a roma alla fine
che pur romantico dolce invece
il rapporto vediamo se qualcosa di
strano vediamo non si prende
male ok è girato mi piaceva quel kraft
speciale con bensì non rigori con rigoni
prezzo prezzo presto che è tardi apriamo
la porta siamo pronti chi scopriremo qui
a lei
fa più paura del solito gigante gigante
gremi gigante verbali secretati
dai tre vorrebbe marziane giganti
anch'io a chi ancora pin questa era
avanti 5 g
guardai sé ma perché ancora non abbiamo
azionato l'elettricità quindi ancora
non era g
c'è qua dentro però il nonno mi sembra
il grinch grinch perché il grinch ho
dentro controlliamo un'altra scatola e
il grigio secondo me chi è dentro quella
stato è anche a me sembrava il grinch
però adesso non riesco a capire sembra
un dinosauro è volato ei non prenderli a
calci di fare sulle bombe di
stiamo li facciamo ci sono fuori magari
li dovranno pure loro diversi dai
controllo altro no voglio vedere se c'è
una cosa c'è dentro
[Musica]
la mano di g mi sembra
ok controlliamo la che cosa è giusto
questo non c'era nel gioco a chi guardi
non c'era neanche in ben di che cos'è
fa paura che se un ragno è una new
zealand
ma perché oramai dice un brunch a me no
per una del regno di tre
fuori
questo non me l'aspettavo non toccarlo
non toccarlo lasciargli gthx che c'era
un altro da pietro si è meglio che non
lo tocchi ok non voglio anche un ragno
che si insegue altra grendi così troppo
paura proprio fa più paura di trevi ma
ecco paura ai ragni no perché c'era il
ragno intendevo perché il regno è un
alleato di greg ma tu non tocca ce ne
sono due uno grande o piccolo sembrano
mortali
che andiate a toccarne ma non fa niente
guarda carino
stavo vedo ragione se ci facciamo poi
piazzare in pace anche lasciamoli puzzle
con altra delle scatole voglio
vedere che bambola c'è dentro scatole
qua non c'è niente forse si vede niente
forse ci sono i raggi in queste scatole
l'ho spedito via lontano risposto
bene di non c'è niente di più ma perché
lo prende a cavallo e non l'ho fatto
apposta ma è vuota vediamone un'altra
qui c'è qualcosa vedi
green dentro tipo che cosa sei madrina
rana che il green su il pupazzo del
green sono grigio non c'entra niente con
g ok allora ora non ci resta che aprire
vita grendi e cioè azionando
l'università la chiave sarà la chiave si
arriviamo
credo che me la chiave la chiave gigante
e la porta da questa sì sì dobbiamo
dobbiamo prima accendere le luci compito
di prodotto non male vero sì per ora si
ok elettricità attivata anche un buco a
vedere e sarebbe scappata è scappata mi
piace chiuso la porta dove sta
scappa va a finire i gremi è andata
nella fa ma ora mi sono ancora qua
questo qua però se ingigantito questa
era quello piccolo è diventato più
grande dove è andato l'altro adesso ha
seguito granny porvi infatti ce n'è solo
vediamo il braccio vediamo se il prezzo
di graham il braccio di grande in cui da
bagno che cos'è non si capitano forse
forse terraneo
strano
stranissimo sembrava un mix tra di wyeth
infatti sembrava il conto di aghi wang
yi però bianco come il vestito di grand
prix
ma c'è il solito buffo dico fuori
presto freddo freddo
ok ok ora mettiamo le quattro cassette
cassette o non so cosa siano noi
prendiamo l'altra mano vediamo se
l'altra mano è normale lo stesso sia un
qualcosa si è attirata no ecco la cura
ma marotta
non è uguale sì ho visto perché in
arrivo a di due cibo biblica in capitolo
ii che usciranno si sa quando ma
perdiamo procura ci dovrebbe essere
un'altra mano verde
ma come sarà è sicuramente ci sarà anche
chi simili non vedo l'ora di vedere
quando girano vedo l'ora di provarlo so
che stiamo andando verso credi gigante
il rullo trasportatore si sta portando
verdi pure
ok stiamo attivando elettricità e ora
sapete cosa succede vero
arriva gremi dobbiamo tutti fare la
fabbrica
sembra che ci siamo rotti di poster
l'osso di un piede
riattivata la fabbrica ora dobbiamo solo
prendere giocato eccolo eccolo e poi
giocattolo questo era il pupazzo
bisognare vi ricordate pure in venti che
c'era un gioco diverso
ok vediamo giocato un paio di
[Musica]
notti
che a trovare stati
preparati e capaci si
stima che moriamo
si deve lui ibra ora in preordine come
il trailer
[Musica]
un mistero da svelare
4 misteriose creature da scoprire
un'avventura che vi lascerà col fiato
sospeso
storie paurose a scuola di misteri e ora
disponibile per il pre ordine su amazon
[Musica]
clicca della linke descrizione per
preordina rettore prof
bravissimi che lo preordina non
riceverete la cartolina rilasciata da
beh è vitale è una storia davvero
vi terrà incollati alle pagine filosofi
non riuscirete a smettere di leggere in
più leggendo accumulerete anche dei
punti alla fine avrete il vostro profilo
in base a tutti così gaga accumulato
quindi sarà come fare una sana ed anche
bellissimo davvero cliccate il link e
descrizione per preordinarlo e ora
vediamo se riusciamo a scappare
sei riuscito a non farti prendere
ancora no aspetta proviamoci
ma che
[Musica]
paura
matera brucia
e provo io questa volta
attenta che fa paura
ma troppa paura ma è bruttissima così
gitante perché questo fattore si
cena e che brutta dal solito cremati più
anti fai fai vai
dove sono finito aspetta non vedo niente
ma sono riusciti a estrarli e dove devo
andare ha detto ok sta andando la parte
giusta perché
non fai i tuoi passi forse non si sta
seguendo
a me ne faccio spesso
ok ora proveremo un'altra cosa e cioè
proveremo a salire sopra e vedere se i
gremi ci guardo se riesce a raggiungerci
vediamo
ok vitale ha già messo le scatole qua
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto scappare dalla
scappa scappa scappa option io vivevo
via prima che sono e non non dovrebbe
riuscire a prendersi vediamo dove
agghiacciato ancora più inquietante ma
come è fatta la testa cioè che
[Musica]
già aggreghino ci puoi fare niente da
qua ora che mi prendo se posso fare
grandi
saremo ancora più su video se si insegue
con lo sguardo come faceva a chi
non la vedo più equi e mondani cina è
sparita testa veti non c'è più la testa
di credito the
granny tentano ti avvicinare troppo
è successa qualche bug strada gragnana
costume e adesso come facciamo possiamo
provare a saltare da qui magari anche da
qua non ha più la testa granny che è
brutto perché
personaggio valvola
la prego oggi abbiamo un altro
personaggio al posto di aghi uag in
personaggio forse uno dei più paurosi di
tutti che siren ed
ora stai
gigantesco una specie di mostro brano
vediamo se il gran pack sarà diverso
questa volta come 20 e poi non vedo
l'ora di vedere anche le scatole dei
pupazzi per vedere se c'è un mini teigen
faccia dei personaggi all'interno si è
grande per la nostra mano presa poiché
noi un po amaro come sarà stai renet
sarà ancora più grande agroppi gigante
ora vedresti bene tutto vediamo
ma che guardi
non ha funzionato
nei voti c'è qua dentro se qualcuno qua
dentro anch'io ma ora
reinserire il modo abbiamo sbagliato
qualcosa ok ragazzi scusate per il
banche di prima ora dovrebbe dare un
pezzo verità scopriremo
un altro filo vediamo piano piano
piano
[Musica]
il mio volto fatto le brutte di sempre
si piega a scoprirlo scopriamo
bruttissimo ma che via via prima che si
raggiunga aiuto
ok sentite i passi sta per questo
primato sono sicuro che qui
qui dove
dovrebbe uscire da lì
no non esce non c'è
no ragazzi molto bene motore del
successo in questo modo ogni tanto
apparati ma che ogni tanto fare stai
renet non capitano vision succedendo se
un bug strano adesso proviamo a fare
un'altra cosa cioè ad avvicinare le
scatole sua e poi proveremo a salire
sopra le scale così vediamo se si guarda
siren e dopo se si guarda ai polacchi
non si capisce queste pagine dover
scappare da tutti e due
vediamo che cosa allora io sono gli
utenti non spostare le scatole ok le
scatole e sono pronte ora andiamo a
chiamare siren ed
magari arese a chi mario cimino
ha questo modo è tutto bagnato
dai commissari e mezzo ok
attento non cadere a tenerci pronti
proprio cipro facciamo molto aiuto che
pochi girati vediamo se
si
è alla stampa colorata e tifo rossoblù
ma sbaglia c'è anche un pezzo di aghi
sottili un pochino a volte vedi sembra
una semplice tra noi chiamiamo c
c'è in questo modo sia stato un bar di
ha fatto un mago insomma
era molto strano molto molto strano però
salire più su vediamo se si muove
vediamo ei
69 sempre lì
dove sei
e ancora lì allora io direi di provare
una cosa proviamo a completare questa
volta così vediamo
allora principe raffaele d'occhi ci sarà
chi vuoi prendiamo devitalizzato poco
prima che il vostro dai dai ricordi
troppo codeghini cellulare si e puoi
farcela puoi farcela facciamo team amore
vita a
tutti piace mi partiva per vitale che
antiche n'è un'altra parte di cui era
uscito equipaggi prima quindi dobbiamo
scappare scappare scappare
dov'era si fa avevo già preso non c'era
nessuno c'era qualcuno a voi avete visto
qualcuno
proviamo l'ultima volta da iren ed è
molto abile molto frutto secondo voi fa
più paura anche molti dei reds
anche perché è un po haghighian che lo
vedeva mica possiamo farvi scappare
sarebbe bello che la fabbrica ma non
giocando aiuto st arrivati
sorpreso questo era il mod styron ed
anche se era tutto un po bagnato
vi lasciamo a quattro cartellini a
semplificare per vedere i nostri altri
video e cade su quella che preferite è
pura visione ciao